[Musik]
das oberste us gericht hat das
landesweit geltende recht auf
schwangerschaftsabbruch gekippt
wirtschaftsminister robert habeck rät
den deutschen weniger zu duschen und du
stehst selbst schneller wegen tut hin
und damit herzlich willkommen meine
damen und herren zu füllen meine gäste
heute abend publizist in den keller die
über das abtreibungsrecht wer jetzt
glaubt dass sich die hölle aufgetan
hätte der er schön dass sie da sind voll
quelle
umweltsenator hamburgs und spd-politiker
professor doktor fritz vahrenholt sagt
die energiewende ist gescheitert wir
stehen vor dem wirtschaftlichen absturz
ich bin gespannt sonntag bei die
richtigen fragen waren wir schon sehr
reger wollte hier jetzt nochmal
sportjournalist und fußball-kommentator
ghailanis bei uns in treibt die
meinungsfreiheit um ich bin gespannt
denn er selbst wurde einmal wohnt eines
wie ich für eine lustige meinen
kommentar von seinem ehemaligen
arbeitgeber sky entlassen darüber werden
wir sprechen schön dass sie da ist und
dann liest man quebec apotheker und
autor des buches stoppten corona mafia
er hätte sicher die politik hat bei den
bürgern tests zum betrügen eingeladen
und die neue krone test verordnung macht
es nicht besser mit 1 fakten wird er uns
gleich alle versorgen und mein name ist
nina schenk ich freue mich dass ich
heute abend ihre gastgeberin sein da und
mein thema heute abend ist man nicht
karl lauterbach sondern robert habeck
und das thema ist duschen ist die neue
freiheit die denken jetzt vermutlich was
für eine dämliche these sagt die frau da
ich hätte das auch niemals gedacht der
sich beim morgendlichen buschland
freiheit denken würde geschafft hat
diese zugegebenermaßen etwas skurrile
entwicklung unser wirtschaftsminister
robert habeck er hat nämlich vor wenigen
tagen dem spiegel gesagt ich halte mich
an das was mein ministerium empfiehlt
meine dusche zeit habe ich nochmal
deutlich verkürzt und weiter ich habe
noch nie in meinem leben länger als eine
minute geduscht fünf minuten geduscht
ich dusche schnell ja das
wirtschaftsministerium hatte vor kurzem
der energiespar tipps für den alltag
veröffentlicht tipps keine verordnung
und nun müsste sich laut haben zeigen
wer bock auf dieses land habe und
anderen helfen wolle ich muss gestehen
mehr als bürgerin ist es völlig egal wie
lange unser wirtschaftsminister bush das
ist seine privatangelegenheit und sollte
es auch bleiben ich möchte auch nicht
wissen wieviel toilettenpapier herbert
pro monat verbraucht oder wie lange er
das wasser beim zähneputzen laufen lässt
es gibt für mich nicht schützen weiteres
als die individuelle freiheit des
bürgers also auch meine und ich möchte
nicht hören dass wenn ich jetzt länger
als eine dusche ich kein bock auf dieses
land hätte ich habe bock habe ich halte
es da eher wie wolfgang kubicki ich
dusche so lange bis ich fertig bin und
jetzt interessiert mich was frau keller
dazu sagen ob sie auch schon beim
duschen die zeit heilt auf die uhr
schaut unter der dusche ja das sage ich
nur mein kind
nein ich dusche ehrlich gesagt kalt und
das mehrere minuten und das ist ganz gut
kreislauf und insofern ich finde das
wahnsinn worüber jetzt alles schon
diskutieren wir wollen jetzt schon
frieren glaube ich für den frieden und
jetzt weniger duschen für das klima ich
bin gespannt was man sich als nächstes
einfallen lässt wo man uns gängeln darf
im namen natürlich immer eines höheren
gutes und es kommt ja immer moralisch
daher also wer jetzt länger als eine
minute duscht habe ich jetzt richtig
verstanden ist moralisch ein kleines
männlein er so einfach ein guter mensch
zu sein so leicht war es noch nie wenn
man nur einen erst ist man dabei ich
würde mir wünschen dass unsere minister
harbeck sich endlich darum kümmert wie
wir alle unsere energiekosten bezahlen
können wie wir ausreichend wasser und
strom haben weil wir leben ja irgendwo
nicht irgendwo in einem dritte welt land
sondern mitten in einem industrieland
und es wäre ganz gut wenn unser
wirtschaftsminister hat das zur kenntnis
nimmt das wäre eigentlich schon mal
weiter waren und dass alles was er
vorschlägt eigentlich ein schritt zurück
ist und
das ist schlicht den staat ja auch wie
sie sagen nichts angeht wenn wir was wir
zu hause in unseren vier wänden wir
können aber natürlich durch protokolle
vielleicht
anders natürlich gesagt weil ich finde
es natürlich ein sehr politisches thema
aber ich glaube eben dass unser nächster
bundeskanzler der habe das schon mit
bedacht an seine ist sabonis einmal die
erste wette heute abend ja das glaube
ich ich glaube dass er
das war schon sehr viel sinn hinter
steckt ich habe auch bevor er mit dem
thema beschäftigt habe hätte ich auch
gedacht mein gott da geht mit getönter
nichts an wie lange ich dusche aber du
kannst wirklich so viel energie sparen
offensichtlich habe das netz nach
gelesen wenn man eben statt zehn minuten
mit 38 grad wäscht löscht
nur acht minuten auf 8 verkürzt kann man
schon so viel kosten und energie sparen
dass das eben wenn jeder sich daran hält
jeder ein bisschen reduziert wirklich
tatsächlich viel eingespart werden kann
aber auch von anderen seite haben wir
hier einfach mal in der zahlen das doch
also wenn ich schreibe vaasa und mein
strom bezahlen kann ich doch verbrauchen
so viel schnee aber wir wollen doch alle
hier möglich dass putin schaden und in
dem wir dann einfach
energie und
energieexperten am tisch verfahren heute
wenn ich jetzt nur noch einem youtube
pro tag dusche und auch meiner schwester
und meinem lebensgefährten erst
beibringen wie sehr schade ich damit
putin also das bringt ich sag mal
im promillebereich ja und das ist das
ärgerliche wir diskutieren etwas was die
gesamte nation beschäftigt aber
thematisieren nicht die wirklichen
probleme die wir mit der energie krise
haben wir haben eine gasknappheit die
vor der folgt eine stromknappheit
die preise liegen uns um die ohren
dreifach fünffache preise aber viel
entscheidender ist ja was ihm der
wirtschaftsminister nicht thematisiert
ist dass über 50 prozent des gases in
die industrie und das gewerbe geht das
geht eben in die metallverarbeitung das
geht in die chemie das geht in die basf
das geht in die brötchen bäckerei und er
weiß natürlich dass es knapp wird und
bereitet das volk ist darauf for mental
aber in wirklichkeit erwarte ich von
einem wirtschaftsminister dass er dafür
sorgt dass die gefährdeten 5,6 millionen
arbeitsplätze die am gas hängt dass er
sich darum kümmert und er hat das ja
versucht indem man in katar an bückling
gemacht hat und gesagt hat wir wollen
bitte euer
gas haben die kataris haben ihn dann
aber abblitzen lassen weil sie sagen
unser gas ist schon längst verheilt sie
habe für fähig genug für das amt des
wirtschaftsministers na ja er hat ein
problem er hat nämlich ist ein grüner
und er kann natürlich nicht aus der
grünen mentalität und die grüne
mentalität sagt ja wir müssen unsere
eigenen
kohlebergwerke stilllegen aber die
gleiche regierung die jetzige hat dem
kolumbianischen präsidenten angebaggert
er möchte doch bitte seinen tagebau
erweitern damit wir kohle kriegen aber
in der lausitz da wären die kohlebergbau
um acht jahre verkürzt das gleiche gilt
um zum gas wir haben über der unter der
norddeutschen tiefebene ein riesiges
erdgasvorkommen für 30 jahre hätten wir
überhaupt kein problem mehr mit putin
mit katar mit wem auch immer wir müssen
es nur fördern weil das will natürlich
keiner das ist schon seit den letzten 20
jahren runter gegangen und man müsste in
etwa 1100 meter tiefe das
schiefergestein erschüttern und dann
kommt das gas raus wir wissen genau wo
es liegt und es gibt experten die sagen
wir können es in einem jahr fördern aber
das tun wir nicht sondern holen uns
flüssiggas aus amerika das übrigens mit
der gleichen technik gefördert wird und
das dritte ist wir wissen alle mitten im
winter am 31.12 werden drei
kernkraftwerke abgestellt und da bietet
sich ja hab ich auch rum und sagt das
wollen wir aber das haben wir ein clip
hat ganz frisch von heute wo olaf
scheint sich dazu äußert
das bringt nichts nicht nicht selber
gucken was in deutschland dem boden
ich glaube in deutschland ist nicht so
viel im boden dass wir diese
abhängigkeit und damit beseitigen können
anzeigen aber leider eben die halbe
wahrheit
und es ist einfach so ich will dass ich
mal wieder
kernenergie kernkraftwerke machen ja nur
strom und keine wärme der fehler ist der
wenn sie kernkraftwerke abstellen wie
das jetzt geplant ist dann müssten
gaskraftwerke hochgefahren werden denn
wir haben ja gar keine genügend
kohlekraftwerke das heißt wir schieben
das gas was so dringend gebraucht wird
in unseren arbeitsplätzen aber auch
zuhause fürs duschen das werden wir
zusätzlich verbrennen und deswegen sage
ich mal auch da ist eine
doppelzüngigkeit am werke wir
importieren aus tschechien aus
frankreich über kernkraft sicherheit der
kernenergie steigen an den wollen wir
nicht mehr den wollen wir nicht mehr
benutzen und das wäre wenn man ein
beispiel geben wenn sie die drei
kernkraftwerke ab stellen in deutschland
dann haben sie so viel strom auf so viel
strom verzichtet wie die gis fast die
gesamte
solarplatten in deutschland also 2,2
millionen solardächer produzieren ja und
das will ja die bundesregierung jetzt
verstärken das heisst also jetzt müssen
wir erstmal fünf bis sechs jahre
solarplatten bauen damit wir überhaupt
das ersetzen was durch die drei großen
kernkraftwerke ersetzen dasding de mehr
kommen wir gleich noch ganz detailliert
zum glück ist ein wichtiges thema aber
ich habe hier schon von der anderen
seite gemerkt neckar aber sprach er das
nein doch ich bin neugierig und zwar
wegen der erdgasvorkommen in der
norddeutschen tiefebene darunter
wie realistisch ist das denn oder wie
schnell könnte man das so zu tage
fördern wir wissen genau wo es liegt es
gibt aber leider in deutschen hat ein
sogenanntes fracking verbot das ist ein
gesetzliches verbot das hat man damals
unter merkel
verabschiedet weil man dachte auch wir
haben doch das wussten gras das ist doch
reichte auch wir müssen uns noch nicht
anstrengen in deutschland wir können
auch einfach so tun als ob stört ja auch
man ist es natürlich klar wenn sie
irgendwo eine gasförderung haben die
nachbarn haben das nicht so gerne es
gibt immer ärger natürlich aber wir
können doch nicht im ernst glauben dass
wir eine so hoch entwickelte
industriegesellschaft wie wir sie sind
versorgen können mit mit mit wind und
sonne wind und sonne machen im gesamten
energiemix gerade mal fünf prozent aus
davon werden wir die nächsten zehn
zwanzig jahre nicht alleine unseren
energiebedarf decken können und deswegen
ist doch die erste bürgerpflicht eines
ministers zu sagen was haben wir denn
selbst dann lass uns mal schnell ein
programm machen dass wir im nächsten im
übernächsten winter das eigene gas das
zweite ist wir fahren die
kohlekraftwerke hoch das geht ja gar
nicht anders und dann werden noch viel
schöner wenn dann sagen würde und dann
scheinen wir das co2 ab bin gewonnen ja
auch dem klima gerade ein rechnung
tragen das kann man ihm das liebste
deutsche technik die kann das co2 oben
stattdessen wird ja vor allem mit
infantilen energiespartipps ich empfinde
es als infantil ist nämlich als mündige
bürgerin der mann nicht zu sagen hat wie
sie duschen soll er ist übrigens auch
ein anderer spar tipp der hing in
düsseldorf an werbebanner die
gefriertruhe und soll man jetzt abbauen
wo ich dachte also das habe ich schon
mit 14 jahren von meiner oma gelehrt
aber gut dass es mir jetzt auch die
politik beibringt aber wie sehen sie das
denn als bürger wenn sie diese
energiespartipps des
wirtschaftsministeriums lese also
persönlich wenn ich das so höre kann ich
nur mit dem kopf schütteln
ich fühle mich bevormundet das heißt ich
glaube jeder hat verstanden dass
klimawandel kommt dass wir uns verändern
müssen aber das kostet ja auch richtig
viel geld das heißt wenn wir unseren
staat wenn wir unsere wirtschaft
schwächen indem wir sagen okay guck mal
wie ihr klarkommt dann werden wir auf
dauer auch den diese energiewende werden
wir irgendwann nicht mehr bewältigen
können weil uns einfach das geld und als
unternehmer habe ich das schon große
sorge bei uns auch die energiekosten
gehen durch die decke und ich kann da
nichts gegen tun denn schätze ich wird
ihnen der die these von herfahren heute
heute gefallen jetzt sind wir nicht bei
ihrem thema angelangt was wir heute
mitgebracht haben worüber sie sprechen
möchten ja das war mal ein thema das wir
seit etwa zehn jahren den seit 2010
eigene energieerzeugung
abgestellt haben zunächst mal die
kernkraft dann wir hatten die sicherheit
von kernkraftwerke der welt
dann haben wir die kohle sozusagen
aufgegeben und haben gedacht wir könnten
das andere besondere und wind machen und
in wirklichkeit man uns aber nicht die
wahrheit erzählt denn in wirklichkeit
ist in der gleichen zeit natürlich der
erdgasimporte immer stärker nach
deutschland aus russland forciert worden
weil das weiß jedes kind aber die
bundesregierung hat uns das nicht allen
erzählt dass so ein windkraftwerk ich
war ja mal selber windkraft unternehmer
ich hab so was wie dünger hergestellt
steht eben öfter als das ist dreht das
ist leider so 20 prozent des jahrestages
eines jahres also 8700 monaten hatten ja
also ungefähr 2000 stunden dreht das
vollers und bei der sonne ist das noch
viel schlimmer die solaranlagen haben
1000 stunden und nach zu gewissen haben
die
scheint die sonne nicht also braucht man
natürlich immer dann wenn erneuerbare
energien die fluktuieren sind ein backup
wieder batterien speichern oder weil wir
es noch nicht haben gaskraftwerke oder
kohlekraftwerke und da man sich
entschieden die kohle wollen wir nicht
und da finde ich ist schon der erste
fehler gewesen der wahr jetzt einfach
weitergemacht wird es gibt eine
deutsche- von deutschen ingenieuren
entwickelte technik die gab's mal in den
schwarze pumpe in brandenburg nicht in
der ehemaligen ddr
war ja alles auf braunkohle ausgerichtet
und da hat man entwickelt eine co2
abscheidetechnik und das abgeschiedene
co2 konnte man dann in die tiefen da
wohnt man gas gefördert hatte zum
beispiel oder unter der nordsee
verpressen dann wären wir das thema
losgeworden und dann hätten ein
wahnsinnigen effekt auf die welt gehabt
denn wir hätten den chinesen sagen
können was mal hoffnung jungs wenn ihr
weiter eure kohle was wir verstehen ihr
habt viel kohle und ist billig wenn ihr
die weitere verwenden wollt dann müsst
ihr aber diese technik anwenden denn wir
wollen mit dem co2 runterkommen aber das
hat man nicht gemacht weil das natürlich
irgendwie ein bisschen schwierig war man
muss den den leuten das ja erklären und
sagen wir wollen das co2 unter dem boden
aber ich habe mich noch erinnert wer das
angestoßen das kann aus schleswig
holstein
der damalige oppositionsführer
robert habeck das ist noch mal sagen da
ja damals gesagt schleswig-holstein
möchte nicht der abfalleimer seien für
co2 aus
er hat uns denn abhängig gemacht von
russischem gas das war doch auch gerhard
schröder und ich meine sie sind auch in
der spd also die spd war doch ja massiv
beteiligt an dem an dem drama in dem wir
uns jetzt befinden dass wir jetzt in
einer unglaublichen abhängigkeit zu
erleben sondern ein weil sie sie für sie
beschuldigen alle waren bis natürlich
würde ihnen auch widersprechen in der
frage dass es dann der erste fehler war
die kohlekraftwerke abzuschalten sondern
oder oder auf kohlekraft zu verziehen
der erste fehler war die auf atomkraft
zu verzichten tja ich eure erlösung und
ist sehr interessant wie sie sich an der
atomkraft vorbei lavieren hier jetzt
gerade in der
atomfrage gibt es nur dann nicht mehr
wenn sie die augen schließen weil jerome
genauso genauso wie es wie china jetzt
demnächst noch einmal 250
kohlekraftwerke bauen wird baut die
ganze welt atomkraftwerke nur
deutschland er jagt seine preise in die
höhe und sagt wir wollen darüber nicht
sprechen das ist hier ein kleines kind
dass die augen zumacht und sagt ich bin
nicht arisch das heißt wenn wir nein sie
wollen ja ernsthaft über die energie
krise reden dann müssen wir natürlich
noch zur verfügung haben wenn wir jetzt
über den winter den nächsten winter
kommen wollen nützt es mir nix zu sagen
natürlich bin ich für neue
kernkraftwerke die sind leider
abgestellt worden in den letzten zehn
jahren in der regierung merkel und
deswegen muss man eigentlich sagen dann
wenigstens das was wir noch haben
vielleicht sogar noch die drei die im
letzten jahr stillgelegt worden sind
reaktivieren und dann endlich auch neue
technologien der kernenergie
entwickeln aber es hilft uns nicht mehr
jetzt zu lamentieren
zwölf sind alle abgestellt und ich halte
es auch für falsch ich habe jetzt nur
erwähnt
wie geht das ja weiter wie kann man
jetzt diese krise lösen und da sage ich
erster erdgas fördern zweitens kohle
weiter und drittens die
anteile atomkraft die wir haben weiter
betreiben und nicht gerade am 31.12
abstellen aber die bundesregierung lernt
nicht dazu das ist das problem sehen sie
heute hat die umweltministerin gesagt
wir wollen ein verbrenner verboten für
2035 das will die durch weiter geht es
um das gelände widersprochen ja aber
eine lehre hat gesagt wir machen das
nicht jetzt hat er sich über den tisch
ziehen hoffentlich
auch auf twitter gesprochen dass sich
das jetzt überrascht also nicht okay
wenn ich junger forscher wir wissen dass
strom jetzt knapp werden wird weil wir
eben nicht genügend erzeugungskapazität
haben und dann ausgerechnet in dem land
wo es knapp wird sagen wir wo wir die
technologie von des verbrechers
entwickelt haben sagen wir wir wollen
das alles jetzt auf e autos machen aber
noch nicht erschlossen das ist derzeit
am dienstag sowie der sehr gespannt wer
sich da durchsetzt ich habe wieder
gehört dass die minister und lamb gesagt
nämlich bleibt dabei doch wohl mal
gucken ob da wirklich dann auch die
koalitionsfrage darstellt und sagt das
machen wir mal zum koalitions thema ich
halte das für dringend erforderlich weil
wir haben immer noch einen stoff der
nicht so knapp ist gas ist wahnsinnig
knapp das wird uns in diesem herbst
ausgehen aber haben wir noch genug öl
und in der situation dann auf strom zu
gehen da kann man nur sagen jeder wer
demnächst ein e fahrzeug sicher oft muss
sie muss ich damit rechnen dass das auch
dann nicht angespannt von gestartet ist
ja auch vor allem die ängste die sich
die bürger jetzt gerade machen wenn sie
jetzt auf den nächsten winter blicken
haben sie auch angst bürger dass das gas
aus geht natürlich habe ich angst als
bürger dass das gas ausgeht dass wir
unseren energiebedarf nicht mehr decken
können weil da hängt ja viel viel mehr
dran da hängt nicht daran ob ich jetzt
warm duschen oder kalte dusche sondern
da hängt
mein komplettes leben im zweifel auch
meinen arbeitsplatz dran und dann erst
werden die unternehmen betroffene
unternehmer kaufen sein es sei denn
dieses kritische infrastruktur aber da
kann man auch wieder diskutieren was ist
denn kritisch was ist denn nicht
kritisch am ende des tages wird es
darauf hinauslaufen dass apotheker
werden sie länger liefert werden das
weiß
ja genau ich dann von theke da ist warm
aber natürlich weiß ich das doch gar
nicht auf was für ideen dann nachher ich
sage mal unsere regierung noch kommen
findet das heißt ich muss ja auch als
arbeitgeber gegenüber meinen
mitarbeitern eine fürsorgepflicht
wahrnehmen und die kann ich nur wenn ich
auch entsprechend energie habe wenn wir
alle mit bluthochdruck heizen könnten
dann werde er eine blutprobe trat
massiv hoch wenn ich sowas höre dass in
anführungsstrichen im herbst und im
winter keine energie nicht mehr da ist
aber ich glaube es kommt so langsam an
heute hat die vorsitzende des deutschen
gewerkschaftsbundes frau fach chemie
gesagt hat die bundesregierung ermahnt
dann hat gesagt diese krise auf die wir
uns jetzt auf die wir zu rennen darf
nicht auf dem rücken der arbeitsplätze
und arbeitnehmer ausgetragen werden sie
hat leider noch nicht den nächsten
schritt getan was müsste sie denn tun
ich werde gerne helfen und das haben wir
jetzt gerade getan indem er sagt ja dann
muss die vorsitzende deutschen bewirkt
und ich frage mich wo wollen sie denn
etwas zurück blicken dass sie sagen mit
dem wissen von heute hätte ich etwas
anders gemacht ist fragt man sich ja
immer als bürger wenn man auf die
politik blick das frage ich mich immer
ob man auch selber kritisch mit sich ins
gericht waren gelang warum willst du und
ich muss ganz offen sagen wie fällt dann
nicht viel ein was ich hätte anders
machen sollen jetzt die kanzlerin ja
aber das sagen auch andere dass bei der
ganzen sache zu sagen dass nicht alle
auch viele sagen auch zu viele ja das
ist richtig
also das ist außerdem schon schon fast
25 jahre her aber
auch ein bisschen gemein verlauf der
kamera gemacht werden gibt es aber die
die frage die sich jetzt wirklich stellt
ist zum beispiel in hamburg wir haben
ein großes kohlekraftwerk das gerade
abgestellt worden und ich jetzt haben
wir wirklich am ende werden die bürger
stromrechnung bekommen bis der arzt
kommt ja und woher der theke oder
apotheker und das geht doch alles nicht
das heißt wir müssen doch mal jetzt mal
innehalten und sagen okay alles zu
seiner zeit im augenblick haben wir uns
dafür zu sorgen dass dieser wohlstand
den wir erarbeitet nicht kaputt geht
also nicht zu denn wenn am ende 5
millionen arbeitsplätze weg sind die
kommen erst mal so schnell
als letzte frage zu der thematik was
sollte denn herr scholz jetzt tun ja es
sollte seinem wirtschaftsminister mal
sagen dass man auf da wird draußen
diskutiert das wie erdgas haben ich
möchte dass genau wissen und ich möchte
gerne eine unabhängige gutachten haben
und ich möchte gerne dass das ein
gesetzentwurf gemacht wird der das
fracking verbot aufhebe und zweitens
möchte ich ganz gerne dass der
forschungsminister die abscheidung von
co2 aus kohlekraftwerken macht und das
dritte ist und selbstverständlich müssen
wir jetzt die brennelemente bestellen
oder bestellen lassen durch die
energieversorger das am ersten januar
nächsten jahres nicht diese drei
kraftwerke die kernkraftwerke abgestellt
werden und unsere unsere not noch mal
vergrößern denn ich sage voraus diese
bundesregierung wird am zweiten januar
wird daran gemessen werden wie sicher
unsere arbeitsplätze sind und wie sicher
wir uns versorgen können denn am ende
wird folgendes passieren sie werden
stromrationierung kriegen wie in
südafrika auf der einen seite wird ein
für drei stunden abgestellt auf der
anderen seite erweitert und jetzt
stromrationierung geben wird wenn wir
das nicht wenn wir das so machen wie das
jetzt im augenblick werden wir damit
rechnen müssen der un chef hat gesagt
wir werden es nicht zum blackout kommen
lassen wenn man den blackout verhindern
als den totalzusammenbruch dann müssen
sie wenn es strom strom knapp ist ihm zu
teilen das heißt sie müssen sagen der
stadtteil kriegt heute morgen der andere
stadtteile haben wo ich süd kriegt denn
übermorgen und in berlin ost kriegt dann
und dann können sie das vermeiden aber
stellen sie sich mal vor was wir dann
sind wir sind dann sozusagen auf dem
status eines entwicklungslandes und das
wird während die bürger nicht hinnehmen
und das wird die regierung am ende
die am kosten die ist es die kommen
nächstes jahr im januar noch mal hier
hin zu analysieren dann schauen wir was
für ein job gemacht warum gemacht hat
und jetzt gehen wir weiter nach amerika
und zum thema abtreibung mit birgit
keller
ja der amerikanische supreme court der
oberste gerichtshof in amerika hat
vergangenen freitag ein historisches
abtreibungs urteil wieder für nichtig
erklärt und damit die debatte um das
lebensrecht von ungeborenen kindern in
amerika wieder auf werkseinstellung
zurückgestellt und man muss sagen das
ist auch gut so und bevor jetzt alle
feministin schnappatmung bekommen und
alle denken das mittelalter sei zurück
nein der oberste gerichtshof hat nicht
das recht auf abtreibung abgeschafft er
hat allerdings die kompetenz wieder
zurückgegeben zu den einzelnen
bundesstaaten der usa das heißt was
jetzt passieren wird ist dass jeder
einzelne staat endlich das recht
bekommen die abtreibungs gesetzgebung so
zu regeln wie die leute in diesem
bundesstaat es für richtig halten das
heißt es wird wahrscheinlich
fristenregelung beratungsregelung und so
weiter geben wie wir es auch in
deutschland haben das gericht hat das
begründet damit dass sie sagen es gibt
kein universales menschenrecht auf
abtreibung und das ist ehrlich gesagt
überfällig denn man muss sehen in den
usa haben wir inzwischen zustände das in
einem bundesstaat new york selbst
lebensfähige vier kilo kinder noch bis
zum einsetzen der wehen mit einer
spritze getötet werden dürfen im
mutterleib man sagt es sind keine kinder
und mit verlaub eine gesellschaft die so
etwas erlaubt die ist nicht modern und
auch nicht emanzipiert sondern suizidal
frau keine das gesetz was ich gelesen
hatte gegen bis zu 28 woche und dann bis
zur 24 woche das war der stand amerikas
generell vorher jetzt ich habe mich
gefragt als ich ihre these vorab gelesen
habe manche staaten hatten ja wirklich
schon das abtreibungsverbot in der
schublade die haben nur darauf gewartet
dass der supreme court ist entscheidet
was mich sehr schockiert hat das möchte
ich gerne einmal mit der runde teil der
staat im ist also in missouri dürfen
jetzt abtreibung gar nicht mehr
vorgenommen werden und was mich wirklich
schockiert hat ist nicht meins bei
vergewaltigung oder inzest sondern nur
wenn ein medizinischer grund vorliegt
und das ist ja die große angst der
feministin eigentlich generell das jetzt
tür und geöffnet wurde dafür dass frauen
gar nicht mehr abtreiben dürfen in den
einzelnen bundesstaaten ich verstehe
durchaus sozusagen diese befürchtung
gleichzeitig sich nur ja zum gesetz ja
das stimmt auch dass diese gesetze auch
in der schublade waren wobei ich mir die
frage stellen was ist eigentlich falsch
daran was ist eigentlich falsch daran
dass ein bundesstaat für sich selbst
entscheidet man muss ja sehen das sind
ja länder von der größe die sind größer
als deutschland
das was hier es ist eine
grundsatzentscheidung die hier verändert
worden ist das nämlich dieser supreme
court gesagt hat wir sind gar nicht
zuständig es gibt kein verfassungsrecht
auf tötung eines ungeborenen menschen
und deswegen sind wir gar nicht
zuständig wir hätten nicht zuständig
sein dürften und mit verlaub wenn in
einem bundesstaat die mehrheit der
bürger eine regierung wird die sagt wir
finden das richtig dass die bürger
finden dass auch richtig wir sind wir
dass wir darüber und heute jetzt gerade
nicht wählen die die die bürger das
würde ich jetzt umgesetzt weil er die
konservativen richter in den supreme
court gesetzt wurden die
republikanischen die frage die ich mir
stelle ist um noch einmal ihre ihre
meinung ganz konkret zu wissen finden
sie es denn richtig
was ihr zum beispiel misery umgesetzt
wurde das bei vergewaltigung nicht
abgetrieben werden darf nur bei
medizinischen grund dass eine frau
beispielsweise sie haben eben überall
vier kilo kind gehören das ist legal in
new york und vier kilo und in china habe
ich selten auch erweitern und in meinem
freundes kreise lebt aber was ich weiß
mich eigentlich interessiert ist die ist
die frage finden sie es denn richtig
dass beispielsweise seien in der
sechsten woche nicht abgetrieben werden
darf fortan regeln vor dem gesetz nicht
vor gericht bei bestimmten vorfällen das
ist ja so wie es in deutschland geregelt
ich denke auch die regelung wie in
deutschland habe das gericht hat
gründers der ich mich gerne beantworten
weil die in der tat die sich sagen wir
haben wir erleben ja dass diese debatte
immer genau an diesen extremfällen sich
ja tatsächlich aus eigenbesitz wurde er
wie es auch in deutschland diskutieren
in deutschland ja nie der normalfall
irgendwie der abtreibung die einfach
stattfindet im übrigen häufig beim
dritten kind das wissen die meisten gar
nicht irgendwie also schultern 90 ist da
nichts sagen es ist gar nicht die dass
das junge 16-jährige mädchen oder die
vergewaltigte frau das heißt diese
sogenannte kriminologische indikation
wie das so schön heißt macht in
deutschland irgendwie 0,1 prozent der
fälle aus oder so das heißt wenn wir uns
darauf einigen können und in deutschland
hatten ja genau deswegen im übrigen ein
hart errungenen kompromiss gemacht dass
man sagt für diese extremfälle müssen
wie eine lösung haben weil keiner von
uns glaube ich auch hier auch ich nicht
einer frau vorschreiben will ein kind
von einem vergewaltiger auszutragen das
sind genau die grenzfälle das problem
ist doch etwas völlig anderes nämlich
der normalfall zudem es geworden ist
dass manche frauen das inzwischen quasi
als nachträgliche verhütung quasi
benutzen oder oder das überhaupt nicht
mehr drüber nachgedacht wird das ist
doch das und ich glaube das ist genau
diese zuspitzung der debatte die auch in
einen amerika stattfindet dass man
einfach sagt die sind in extreme
abgedriftet sie sie führen debatten wo
sie sagen das ist noch kein mensch ist
es jetzt nicht das andere extrem zu sein
ist das ist das andere extrem und das
zeigt für mich zeigt es sehr gut was in
amerika passiert erstens mal dass man
sagen muss diese debatte kann man nicht
festhalten man muss vernünftige lösungen
finden und in amerika hat man jetzt 50
jahre extrem in eine richtung gearbeitet
und jetzt ist es genau wegen dieser
extreme ist es jetzt gekippt und dieses
wieder freigegeben und ich glaube es
wird in amerika jetzt harte debatten
geben um das in ein gleichgewicht zu
bringen auch mit fristen lösungen
vielleicht auch mit beratung was ich für
sehr sehr wichtig halte weil ich kenne
das selber ich kenne selber diese
situation dass man ungewollt schwanger
ist und völlig ungeplant und dann ist es
wichtig dass man nachdenkt dass man kurz
innehalten kann dass man auch menschen
um sich hat die nicht alle nur sagen oh
mein gott du bist schwanger sondern
vielleicht auch irgend jemand findet der
sagt oh toll du bist schwanger denkt
drüber nach willst du bist du sicher
habe ich 48 stunden darüber nach in
deutschland haben sie drei tage in
deutschland haben sie drei tagen sie
haben die beratungspflicht und ich halte
diese beratungspflicht für wirklich
wichtig nicht um frauen zu gängeln
sondern um ihnen eine atempause zu geben
und um ihnen im prinzip zeit zu gewinnen
diese teilweise nicht haben die sie auch
nicht haben auch das ich kenne viele
beraterin am telefon beraten junge
frauen über die hälfte sagen sie werden
eigentlich von ihrem partner getrennt
ja der partner sagt ich will das kind
nicht so ja das ist keine
selbstbestimmte entscheidung mehr für
eine frau er eine frau die im stich
gelassen wird ja die aldi das gefühl hat
alleine dazu steht eigentlich müssten
alle feministin auf der straße sein und
gegen diese männer kämpfen um diesen
frauen weil diese frauen
treiben oft nicht abweisen weil sie
sagen ich will kein kind haben sondern
weil sie sagen keiner steht zu mir ja
der mann lässt mich setzen
genau führt die diskussion in den usa
nicht dazu dass wir am ende 50
verschiedene regelungen haben das ja
auch hinter das dann am ende abtreibungs
tourismus entsteht dass jeder dann
entscheidend in new york geht das aber
alles genau ist eigentlich das problem
das ist ein richtiger kontinent wo ist
eigentlich das problem dass es
unterschiedliche regelungen gibt in
verschiedenen statt es haben jetzt schon
firmen entschieden also verschiedene
firmen haben jetzt schon gesagt sie
würden den mitarbeiterinnen die
betroffenen sind abtreibungs urlaub
bezahlen also dann können sie in anderen
staaten oder wie peter mit dass die
reibung
urlaubsort haben sie das wort kurz die
villa ermöglichen wenn sie es also ein
obwohl da hat er um sein um irgendwohin
zu reisen um sein kind umzubringen und
dem arbeitgeber bezahlt das ist nicht
wie perfide das ist das ist eigentlich
kapitalismus pur ja der arbeitgeber
bezahlt way of drive genius
prozess nicht unterbricht
anstatt dass der arbeitgeber sagt wir
helfen dir dein kind großzuziehen du von
dir ist auch dein job nicht und er
zahlen dem mutterschaftsgeld das würde
ich als sozial empfinden aber ein
arbeitgeber der sagt ich bezahle die die
antreiber
auch gegen die abtreibung beispielsweise
der sechsten woche ich bin da gea ist ja
auch ein extrem jahr innerhalb kilo als
sie auch ja aber dass schüler das
schlimme sind das schlimme ist endlich
die grund argumentation die dahinter
stehen weil diese die sagen ja das ist
doch kein mensch das hat das der hat
noch keine menschen im innkreis saal
nebenan holt man aber frühchen mit 500
gramm und pc mit allen regeln der kunst
auf weil man sagt das ist doch unser
kind ja das heißt man muss sich doch als
gesellschaft einmal festlegen gewährt
sagt das ist ein kind dann darf man es
nicht einfach fragen den mal ein mann
herein wenn ich mache jetzt was ich gar
nichts böses mit ihnen bei dem team ein
mann
braucht
aber jetzt ihre meinung dazu sagen
obwohl sie keine frau sind kein kind
bekommen können aber ist ein
potenzieller fährt man hasst ihn nur die
männer warum soll ich nage wissen männer
ja aufpassen so sie also noch dreifacher
vater blut ich finde dass man frauen
generell
die entscheidung überlassen soll es bin
ich nicht ganz ihrer meinung ich finde
frauen soll man bis zur woche iks die
entscheidung selbst überlassen ohne wenn
und aber ob sie abtreiben wollen oder
nicht ist für mich einfach mal also wie
das deutsche modell eigentlich ist
wir fragen erfahren ich glaube wir haben
da so eine lange diskussion gehabt dass
wir uns alle daran orientiert haben und
damit meinen frieden der aber im
augenblick scheint es ja sozusagen dass
er
die bewegung dahin geht dass wieder
auszudehnen und insofern muss man sagen
wir haben glaube ich mittlerweile den
guten kompromiss in deutschland gefunden
und bin und wenn sie auf amerika blicken
was haben sie da empfunden bei der
nachricht ist dort jetzt vom gericht aus
auf jeden fall nicht mehr legal ist ja
das ist glaube ich das ist
verfassungsjuristen da muss man glaube
ich wirklich sagen da gebe ich befehle
recht der spruch der sagt das ist jetzt
kein es gibt kein menschenrecht auf
tötung des kindes das hat steht nicht in
der verfassung dass muss jetzt jeder
staat für sich entscheiden müssen immer
sehen das ist ja amerika besteht eben
von san francisco bis new york aus ganz
vielen staaten und da hat jeder eine
andere tradition da gibt es also
gewaltig ganz anders als san francisco
und da musste jedes land das für sich
empfinden aber ich glaube es gibt ein
paar dinge die müsste man schon als
korsett vorgeben eines wer zum beispiel
für mich die die ungewollte
schwangerschaft durch verbrechen und
ähnliches dass das würde ich sagen das
sollte man eigentlich für sonnen
vereinten staaten von amerika generell
respektieren scheint nicht der fall zu
sein viele feministinnen wie frank eller
gesagt war auch ich sagen würde die
normale frauen und männer dürfen
übrigens für die ist es auch einen
aufschrei und ich glaube ich stehe jetzt
nicht im verdacht eine woge feministin
zu sein die immer für alles ist aber ich
kann schon dieses signal von 1972 wieder
rückgängig zu machen und zu sagen jetzt
ist abtreibung nicht mehr legal das hat
mich so sehr gestört frau keine weil da
fand ich wurden wir frauen wirklich
wieder mit blick des gerichtes
eigentlich zurückgeworfen und zwar um
viele viele jahrzehnte und dass man muss
aber sehen das ja viele frauen okay ich
bin ja auch anders als sie also das ist
ja auch nicht ein kampf für mich frau
gegen mann oder sogar sondern wir sehen
dass das sowohl unter männern als auch
unter frauen völlig unterschiedliche
positionen zu diesem thema gibt und dass
man darüber einfach die debatte wieder
eröffnet hat also theoretisch wie ich
sagen steht es jedem bundesstaat in den
usa jetzt zu tatsächlich wieder alles zu
legalisieren das ist ja überhaupt kein
thema es gibt eben es ist freigestellt
so das heißt es wird jetzt die debatte
eröffnet und dann wird es ein
demokratischer prozess sein und dann
wird darüber abgestimmt werden insofern
sage ich die debatte ist offen sie ist
nicht sagen das un gericht hatte nicht
ist egal das hat nur gesagt ihr müsst
jetzt alle frau keller wir wissen ja
schon die einzelne vor allem
republikanische staaten in amerika jetzt
entscheiden werden also es ist jetzt nur
ein beispiel was ich heute mitgebracht
hat mit mir sorry aber wir können uns ja
sicher sein dass staaten folgen werden
das ist nicht die reha aber normal wenn
die menschen die in diesem staat leben
eine waffe so für richtig empfinden und
deswegen so eine regierung wählen wir
sind wir denn dass wir ihnen das
vorschreiben dass sie es anders machen
sollen also mich wundert ein bisschen so
zu sagen warum wir uns gedanken machen
darüber weil weil gerade auch weil es ja
ein großes land ist und gerade weil man
auch nur über die grenze fahren muss um
es doch machen zu lassen wenn man es
will ja ist dass ich bin sicher dass
quasi dass das jetzt schon daran
gearbeitet wird das in wenn in
bundesstaaten ist nicht möglich ist dass
die frauen das kostenlos woanders
bekommen das wird alles passieren aber
ich halte es für legitim und ich halte
es auch für angebracht da soja
angesichts von wirklich millionen
abtreibungen
dass wir darüber nachdenken ist das
eigentlich richtig und wenn wir mit
derselben energie daran arbeiten würden
auch in deutschland da haben wir etwa
100000 abtreibungen jedes jahr ja weil
immer noch frauen in deutschland glauben
sie könnten und in dort unter deutschen
bedingungen ihr kennt nicht bekommen ja
wenn wir uns mit derselben energie mit
der wir dafür sorgen dass sie ihr kind
loswerden können dafür sorgen würde dass
sie ihr kind kriegen können ja dann
hätten wir auch ein problem gelöst und
das wäre ein problem lösung für die frau
das wäre für mich echte frauenarbeit und
echte frauen politik dass wir den frauen
ermöglichen zu sagen die sag ja zu
deinem kind und nicht wir bezahlen die
die abtreibung der schlussphase ihre
these gehört in front ich bin in einen
ganz kurzen unterbrechungen sind gleich
wieder zurück
[Musik]
also da kann ich dann ein lauter
brauchen nicht ernst nehmen als
sogenannten experten
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren beide sind 85 köpfen sind
meinungen jeder von uns hat ein thema
mitgebracht was ihn bewegt freut oder
schockiert
[Musik]
so nicht privat jet buschi hergiswil
wetten
aber niemand von den politischen
parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur freiheit diese
grün-roten der damen führen hochtrabende
debatten über die rettung des weltklimas
und um die füße russland die ratten das
thema ist viel zu wichtig um es nur
derart zu überlassen lasst den leuten
spaß wir sehen ja etwas was eigentlich
fatale ist in der politik bei den
journalisten deren job ist es doch
gerade abweichende meinungen zu finden
und sie sollen den doch auch richtig
dürfte sein dass ich morgen eines conti
zum manko vielleicht einmal kurz einsatz
doch das ist übliche anorak träger aus
dem becken ich habe meinen beifall über
eine sache immer bekommt er kümmert sich
darum niemand ist so helle den anderen
ist er ganz klein auch darüber sprechen
dass ein tag nicht fertig richtig durch
die aufgabe von journalismus einfach die
die verlautbarungen der politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
vielleicht noch
wir sind zurück und kam jetzt zu einem
thema was uns hierbei film nachts oft
umtreibt und was uns gar nicht
auftreiben kann und sollte und das ist
die meinungsfreiheit und ob man in
deutschland klartext sprechen kann ich
freue mich sehr dass wir hier ich finde
wir haben wir einen experten damit weil
sie mir wirklich schon mal nachteil
dadurch gab dass sie eigentlich ihre
meinung gesagt habe ja meine meinung wir
sehen keine angst vor klartext das hat
eben einen besonderen grund weil ich
nämlich bei sky gefeuert worden bin
damals weil ich zwei äußerungen getätigt
habe die auf twitter zunächst einmal
sehr negativ beurteilt wurden und dann
aus meiner sicht hat dann der konzern
sky viel zu vorschnell gehandelt und hat
mich damals
rausgeworfen und zwar weil ja nicht
jeder genau weiß welche sprüche das
waren ich habe einmal zu sophia thomalla
bezug genommen die hatte ein freund
loris karius der bei union berlin im tor
stand das heißt stand ich im tor sondern
saß auf der bank und ich hab dann in
einem kommentar gesagt naja für eine
kuschel nacht mit sophia thomalla würde
mich auch auf die bank setzen da hatte
ich einen sexismus shitstorm ohne ende
und damals wollte mich schon raus werfen
aber eben auch das finde ich daneben
bitter dass ein großer konzern so sich
von twitter orientieren lässt und
dadurch schon gehandelt hat oder haben
sie sich damals gesagt naja wenn doch
ein spruch von ihm kommt von deilmann
dann schmeißt man wirklich raus und dann
war eine situation dass ein japaner aufs
tor geschossen hat und da habe ich dann
formuliert was wäre sein erster treffer
in deutschland gewesen den letzten hat
er im land der sufis erzielt ich muss in
beiden fällen sagen sowie sophia
thomalla mit ihr habe ich telefoniert
die hat darüber gelacht ja gesagt für
mich persönlich ist das ein kompliment
ich habe mich gefreut über den spruch
die betroffene also selbst hatte
überhaupt nichts dagegen und bei den
japanerinnen japanern war es so dass die
mir geschrieben haben hat gesagt wir
sind das land der so schön stolz darauf
es ist natürlich so ein bisschen der
hintergrund ist dass so schmal
doppeldeutig bewerten kann man kann
damit all die köstlichkeiten meinen dass
ich natürlich gemeint habe man kann aber
auch abfällig damit japaner gemeint
haben aber das lag mir total fern und
völliger blödsinn
wieso was unterstellen und dann hätte
ich eigentlich gesagt dass keine
professionelle einstellung gewünscht hat
sie aber nicht gezeigt ja wir
natürlich mehr aufgehört dass die
toleranz
zu schlecht und die toleranz polizei in
den unternehmen muss nächstes jahr auch
so ähnlich gegangen nicht als ich mich
kritisch zum klima in der
klimaentwicklung geäußert habe mich bin
ich auch gefeuert worden wo sie glaubten
bei der deutschen wildtier stiftung habe
ich gesagt es gibt natürlich auch
natürlichen einfluss auf das klima ist
doch jedem geläufig ist hat auch ganz
kleine reise gefeiert oder gefeuert wird
drei jahren und das ist einfach so weil
die entscheider möchten den schießstand
vermeiden nicht entscheiden möchten
gerne
angepasst sein sozusagen im mainstream
schwimmen und wenn sie aus der
mainstream irgendwo nur ein bisschen
schräg oder
anders auffallend erscheinen dann werden
sie gedeckelt und möglicherweise auch
mit mit
existenznot versehen aber das zeigt eben
eine
wie soll ich sagen eine eine hegemonie
einen eine macht der der der
der medien und des mainstreams die
gefährliches warum weil wir solche leute
wie sie oder die anderer meinung sind am
ende brauchen wenn wir nach vorne kommen
wollen es ist ja nicht so dass der menzl
immer recht hat ganz im gegenteil ja
früher war er denkt ein kompliment
wichtig wer denkt da war ein kompliment
jetzt ist querdenker das absolute no go
das ist auf der sonst was ja
und wenn wir das nicht wieder
wertschätzen die die abweichende meinung
der kritik und aber auch mal nimmt in
den witz und vor allen dingen der wird
also finde es ist was was wirklich als
erstes beerdigt worden ist das
eigentlich der humor in der debatte oder
dass man eigentlich überhaupt kein
scherz mehr machen kann dass alle über
empfindlich sind ja wir haben irgendwie
so eine pussy generation die die einfach
nichts mehr erträgt mir viel aber gerade
ein weil sie jetzt wie man man hat sie
also gefeuert weil die japaner als susis
bezeichnet haben
sie haben diesen begriff
gott wir haben unsere regierung ist
gerade dabei eine antidiskriminierungs
beauftragte ins amt zusätzlich die offen
die deutschen als caravan bereich und
richtig und das scheint irgendwie kein
skandal als verein sie sollten sie bei
skype wieder einklagen
es ist einfach traurig oder
emotional also ich hab gerade überlegt
also wie es für mich wäre ich habe mich
in die lage versetzt versucht mir ist ja
noch nicht passiert ich habe ja wie
furchtbar ist für mich wäre wenn ich
hier irgendwie salopp was sage und dann
plötzlich axel springer sagt goodbye das
würde mich ehrlich gesagt in den
grundfesten erschüttert wir reden über
sport nicht über irgendwas nicht sehr
überrascht weil das team sagte mir meine
kollegen moderatoren und kommentatoren
sind supertypen aber in der
führungsspitze sage ich immer mit
amateuren gewinnt so kann die champions
league
sind wirklich leute die auch unlust ich
bin die einfach kein humor selbst haben
die haben einen knick herausgebracht was
man sagen darf was man nicht sagen darf
und
danach man darf nicht farbige sagen man
soll aber sagen people of colour wo man
eben sagen mein großer unterschied über
über gender da
kenne ich die meinung dazu finde ich ja
ganz fürchterlich ehrlich ich bin ein
gegner von gender ich sage aber immer
ich respektiere die leute die gendern du
die leute die gendern sollen mich nicht
zu zwingen zu ändern die sollen mir auch
die freiheit lassen weiterhin zu sagen
80.000 zuschauer im signal iduna park
und ich möchte dich sagen
die haben das schere im kopf und
überlegen sich jetzt genau was sie sagen
das schöne ist dass ich wirklich einen
sehr großen zuspruch erhalten habe auch
von kommentatoren von anderen sender
béla réthy zdf tom bartels ard marcel
reif
der geschätzte bild kollege und so
weiter und so fort von vielen leuten
wirklich unterstützen selbst eltern hat
sich dann in einem video für mich stark
gemacht hat gesagt wo sind wir denn
eigentlich hier warum was darf man
überhaupt noch in deutschland sagen wir
übertreiben einfach in deutschland ich
lebe zum großen teil in spanien und da
zum beispiel sagt man zu kindern sagt
man - das ist der männliche begriff man
sagt aber in spanien nicht - in mias um
kinder damit sowohl in der linkshänder
aber bei uns wird das eben übertrieben
aus meiner sicht und wir sollten einfach
mal wieder ein bisschen runterfahren es
kann ja auch existenzen zerstören wenn
es jetzt vor allem vielleicht auch
jüngere kollegen trifft die auch noch
nicht vorgesorgt haben oder noch nichts
anfangen konnten was könnte man denn
dagegen tun also gab es von ihrer seite
irgendetwas was noch sie hätten tun
können um gegen sky zu gewinnen
außerhalb des öffnens zu springen das
war ohnehin unnötig weil mein vertrag
tiefe aus deswegen war das purer
aktionismus das was sie gesagt haben die
wollten sich einfach nur selbst schützen
davor die aber was ich denen einfach
vorwürfe bei sky das kalt führung dass
sie einfach sich von twitter so leiten
lassen sie sollen einfach nur abwarten
jeder der schon mal schützt uns erlebt
hat
[Gelächter]
wir hatten einen fall von nils kaben
beim zdf ein interview wie toni kroos
geführt hat war ein bild auch großes
thema
weil er sehr negativ gefragt hatte eben
nach dem champions-league-sieg da hatte
auch nils kaben sehr viel shitstorm
abbekommen da hat der redaktionschef
gesagt thomas fuhrmann leute lasst doch
mal die kirche im dorf und beruhigt euch
mal wieder das war sicherlich nicht
glücklich formuliert aber war auch von
toni großer überreagiert also nimmt er
eben viel aus den segeln raus und so
hätte ich mir das auch von sky gewünscht
so hätte ich das als kairos gemacht ja
ich hoffe mal dass wir eines tages
gefeiert werden dann
muss man doch genau muss man ja gerade
eigentlich auch die eigenen leute
verteidigen und auch das freie wort
verteidigen denn wir sagen wir machen
uns ja unseren eigenen job kaputt also
wenn quasi weil man nennt das diesen
chilling effect auch also dass man sie
feiert ist ja im prinzip kühlt auch die
kollegen rund hin und sagt ihr
vorsichtig weißer raum nächste
eigentlich ja und man schneidet sich als
medienbetrieb in deren eigener doch
lange gern ein der nicht mehr gereicht
max genau und und die sägen an ihrem
eigenen ast die sägen an ihrem eigenen
angst und wenn ich mir das publikum an
kunden oder die ihn jetzt wahrscheinlich
genauso sie haben wahrscheinlich von
ganz normalen menschen wahnsinnig viele
zuschriften bekommen die alle sagen was
soll der schwachsinn und das ist doch
alles völlig in ordnung das heißt die
menschen da draußen denken an dass die
wollen wie man so schön sagt frei
schnauze leben oder wenn wir nicht mehr
frei schnauze reden können
ich möchte unbedingt dass wir thema noch
dran
und deswegen zeigt dass sie die
geschichte geteilt habe ich finde das
sehr wichtig und willkommen aber jetzt
ihn damit sie auch nicht später sagen
die forschung hat mein thema nicht so
gelang es gut
seit drei jahren sind wir dann einer
corona pandemie und die staatlichen
maßnahmen hinten dem alltag immer
hinterher die regierung hat bei den
bürger test versagt sie hat zum betrügen
eingeladen und die neue test verordnung
von karl lauterbach macht das ganze
nicht besser sondern es
verschlimmbessert die situation
ich bin selbst inhaber eines
testzentrums eine apotheke wir testen
seit über einem jahr und ständig müssen
wir immer wieder neue regelungen über
uns ergehen lassen die regierung fährt
eine stop and go strategie im herbst
wurden bürger test abgeschafft drei
wochen später haben wir sie wieder
zugelassen und nun das gleiche nochmal
die regierung ist nicht lernfähig das
ist meine these am heutigen abend und
darüber diskutiere ich gerne mit ihnen
das ist ein sehr spannend fand das nicht
lernfähig es haben ja auch viele bei den
bürger tests abkassiert also ich habe
auch gehört von verschiedenen menschen
das sind ja schon mit dem testzentrum
einer hat sogar mal seinen kontoauszug
stolz und freundeskreis herumgezeigt am
anfang konnte man wohl sogar nur strich
machen und man muss aber das gar nicht
digital anmelden hat da die regierung
auch nichts gelernt da hat die regierung
auch nicht gelernt das ist ja im grunde
genommen der ur fehler des ganzen das
man je erlaubt ein testzentrum
aufzumachen ohne medizinische expertise
ohne inler euro nein leistungserbringer
im gesundheitswesen zu sein der geprüfte
sich als apotheke wenn ich eine apotheke
öffnen muss ich muss meine approbation
abgeben ich muss ein führungszeugnis
hinterlegen ich muss mein
steuerrechtlich da habe ich nicht
aufgefallen sein das heißt ich bin immer
in der prüfpflicht und jetzt auf einmal
darf jeder testen ohne eine gewisse
schulung 20 minuten online schulung hat
glaube ich ausgereicht konnten sie es
denn am anfang auch mit strich lässt da
werden ohne die personalabteilung
natürlich und ich bin ganz ehrlich von
meiner arbeit auch ehrlich gesagt das
ist doch wie betrug
die einladung zum betrug von der
regierung ein und das sagen und das hat
die regierung im letzten jahr ja schon
nach zwei monaten gemerkt dann haben sie
jetzt erst einmal nachgeschärft aber
nach schärfen heißt nicht mehr
kontrollen sondern nachschärfen ist
erstmal die vergütung zu reduzieren und
das gleiche haben sie jetzt ein jahr
später noch mal gemacht das heißt die
vergütung ist nochmal fast halbiert
worden und wir schaffen damit ein
bürokratiemonster weil was ist man unter
dem strich gutes geld damit verdient
natürlich verdient man damit gutes geld
aber man muss auch sagen wenn man es
wirklich qualitativ hochwertig macht mit
geschulten personal mit ordentlichen
räumlichkeiten wir reden nicht über ein
müdes für den test ich glaube 12 euro
oder am 11 am anfang gab es 18 euro
versehen und sollten dann wurde es als
ob 50 runtergegangen und jetzt sollen
ist in bestimmten fällen neun euro 50
seien in anderen 06 eur 50 da muss der
bürger eine zuzahlung leisten von drei
euro details zum einkauf im einkauf das
kommt immer darauf an also die
testphase ist immer weiter runter
gegangen das heißt im moment kaufen wir
ein für einen euro fünfzig ungefähr man
muss aber fairerweise auch sagen da
gehört ja noch viel viel mehr zu wenn
man qualitativ hochwertig macht da
gehört eine schutzausrüstung zu der
gehören masken zu desinfektionsmittel
mieten etc pp aber die arbeit in euro
waren dann viel zu hoch gegriffen und
natürlich veränderungen also wenn ich
sehe einen euro fünfzig waren einseitig
ein mathematiker dass sein damals war
die waren die war der wareneinsatz
deutlich höher das heißt die regierung
hat nach geschäft was sie aber nicht
gemacht hat dass uhr problem zu lösen
und zu sagen wir kontrollieren schaaf
swr pellets mehr kontrolle nein nicht
mit nein nicht mehr kontrolle mehr
kontrolle bringt am ende nicht noch die
neue test verordnung wird dazu führen
dass jeder der möchte nicht im
anführungsstrichen kostenlos kann testen
lassen sondern im grunde genommen sich
zurück zu besinnen darauf dass man sagt
man lässt ist nur die machen die das
auch qualitativ hochwertig machen die im
system bekannt sind und die auch
vielleicht in drei jahren noch bei einer
steuerprüfung zu fassen sind wie viele
firmen werden nach dem ende der korona
teste liquidiert und sind dann für den
staat gar nicht mehr zu fassen kann
keine bereuen sie jetzt als sieg ein
testzentrum aufgewandt haben also wenn
ich mehr so durchlese da muss ich sagen
da kann ich eigentlich anstatt
journalisten lieber auch mal eins auf
machen doch vom halben jahr ja durchaus
ich hatte gesehen bei uns im ort hat
irgendwie ein chinese geschlossen und
aus den räumlichkeiten war tatsächlich
testzentrum und so ging es ja vielen die
haben sozusagen gesagt na gut wenn wir
den laden die so zu machen müssen dann
machen wir eben dass ich endlich was ich
versteh ich finde dass das ist ja auch
marktwirtschaft ja das ist einfach
offene marktwirtschaft dass man dass man
sagt wenn der staat ist zulässt warum
soll ich es nicht tun wenn die leute
sagen ihr nehmt mir meinen job er macht
mir mein geschäft kaputt also muss ich
mir ein anderes suchen und dann ist das
eben ehrlich sagen wenn man so
fahrlässig handelt dann braucht man sich
nicht wundern aber wir haben ja auch
andere dinge also ich meine dass wir
irgendwann fangen wie auch unsere
bundesregierung hat sich ja
dilettantisch angestellt bei allen
möglichen dinge ich weiß ich was wir im
einkauf für die zwei masten bezahlt
haben oder im endeffekt bezahlen ja auch
alles wir ja also was mich stört
eigentlich ist dass all die menschen die
diese falschen entscheidungen getroffen
haben überhaupt nicht haftbar gemacht
werden wenn wir das alle wären ja dann
wären wir schon längst fällig wir werden
schon längst stelle ich aber in der
politik muss nie eingehen als das karl
lauterbach
dass er immer noch im amt ist ist
eigentlich ein wahnsinn aber
auch aldi fehl entscheidungen die
getroffen worden sind all die milliarden
muss man sagen die rausgeworfen sind wir
kaufen impfdosen ein die wir
anschließend wieder entsorgen ja niemand
wird haftbar gemacht dafür für dieses
user management und hier bezahlen das
als bürger alle am schluss das ärgert
nicht dabei der ende gegangen
aber das ist ja im grunde genommen dass
das problem dass man im grunde genommen
ohne sinn und verstand maßnahmen er
lässt und regelungen er lässt ohne zu
wissen was das in der praxis bedeutet
diese neue test verordnung geht ist
völlig weltfremd wer soll denn im
testzentrum kontrollieren es heißt wenn
man in innenräumen veranstaltungen
besucht dann hat man darf man weiterhin
test bekommen wenn man ältere leute
besucht die über 60 sind dann darf man
weiterhin einen test bekommen wie soll
ich das denn im testzentrum überprüfen
ihr könnt das sie können wir können das
neben der durch verordnung neben den
dusch protokoll können wir jetzt auch
das besuchs- protokolle unsere
verwandten ja aber glaubt sie
protokollieren und doch tut und dann
bilder des tages muss man ja wirklich
sagen herr lauterbach sagt ja mit
weniger test wird die qualität besser
und die test werden wertvoller das doch
vollkommen unfähig gas ist er alt sind
wir wünschen uns weniger bürokratie und
mehr für den bürger auch das meer über
bleibt herzlichen dank an meine gäste
das war spannend heute es wurde auch
viel privates erzählt und damit freue
ich mich auf morgen abend soll dann wird
wieder genauso spannend ich wünsche
ihnen noch einen schönen abend tschüss
bis morgen
[Musik]